[Musique]
bonsoir dont elle c'est mon vrai nom
voilà ça s'écrit comme une dentelle mais
au masculin
et moi je travaille sur l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes alors 6e des
psys lacanien dans la salle ce cadeau me
remerciez pas j'y suis pour rien je dis
ça parce qu'en fait la can
lacan disait on est prisonnier du
signifiant prisonniers du signifiant or
précisément quand on travaille sur
l'égalité femmes-hommes montage de ne
pas être prisonnier de ce signifiant qui
restreint notre façon de voir nos façons
de penser
le signifiant c'est tout ce que notre
imaginaire collectif nous raconte
d'image stéréotypée de vision toute
faite de clichés par exemple c'est ce
qui fait que si je pense conquête
je vois des hommes capitaine d'armée des
hommes capital d'industrie des hommes à
la proue de navire des âmes de western
des hommes qui vont sur la lune bref des
hommes qui conquiert des espaces
virtuels ou réels symbolique ou non des
espaces des territoires et parfois des
femmes
voilà ce que notre imaginaire collectif
nous raconte que les hommes sont des
sujets désirant conquérant et les femmes
sont des objets de désir de conquête
pourquoi fin mai d'où ça nous vient à ça
c'est une question qu'on adore se poser
d'où ça vient
qu'on regarde et qu'on traite
différemment les femmes et les hommes
on adore cela posé parce qu'en fait
cette question et nous permet très
régulièrement à savoir à peu près chaque
samedi soir avec les copains autour
d'une bouteille de vin de refaire le
grand match
mature contre-culture alors voilà
comment ça se passe à ma gauche mais
tout ça c'est une affaire d'éducation
évidemment les garçons sont plus
concurrents parce que on les entre on
l'y encourageait turbulent avoir de
l'élan a osé et c'est alors que les
filles au collége lui la petite poupée
aux métaux salue pas gérer c'est pas
grave et humide pour est peut-être même
en reste avec maman et à ses côtés sur
la comment veux-tu quel est l'esprit de
conquête
à ma droite c'est gentil tu es très
comme enfin tu vois bien qu'il ya des
différences entre les femmes et les
hommes quand même enfin puis la conquête
ou face quand même un peu une énergie à
voir avec les hormones la testostérone
on en a où on en a pas quoi à ma couche
à tata c'est en train de me dire que
parce qu'il y aurait des différences ça
justifierait les inégalités ça c'est les
relous l'égalité toujours dans
l'idéologie toujours dans l'utopie
regarde on est différent en et inégaux
c'est pas grave on a juste à jouer la
carte de la complémentarité ou alors ça
ça peut durer longtemps en fait ça dure
jusqu'à épuisement des bouteilles devant
un
et puis le lendemain on se réveille avec
la gueule de bois mais rien de rien de
rien n'a changé sur le front des
stéréotypes et des inégalités alors
peut-être que c'est parce qu'on pose pas
bien la question et que peut-être que la
question qu'il faut se poser c'est pas
d'où vient l'énergie de la conquête
savoir s'il ya un autre script des maux
de tête ou de quelque chose qui
planerait comme ça dans l'air ambiant
mais où va l'énergie de la conquête vers
quoi
l'énergie de la conquête nous projette
nous dirigent quelqu'un a dit l'énergie
bien diriger peut tout accomplir
l'énergie bien diriger peut tout
accomplir alors cette personne si ça
vous ennuie pas j'aimerais bien quand
même pour les coûte parce que en matière
de concatel s'y connaissait un petit peu
alors cette personne
voilà fait un tour du monde en 72 jours
sol en 89 1889 elle a inventé le
reportage d'investigation en immersion
elle est parti enquêter au mexique à une
époque où aucun journaliste ni était
allée elle s'est fait interner
volontairement dans un asile
psychiatrique pour les besoins d'un
reportage
elle a infiltré le monde des trafiquants
pour voir comment ça se passait dans la
mafia
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait d'autres ah oui
elle a été entrepreneur dans l'industrie
et puis à 50 ans passés
eh ben elle est partie son front la
guerre 14-18 pour couvrir les évènements
cette personne c'est nelly blaye
l'énergie bien diriger peut tout
accomplir alors nelly blaye il n'était
pas du tout prévu qu'elle soit
journaliste reporter globe-trotter dans
pour elle on avait pensé aux métiers de
dames de compagnie c'est bien aussi
c'est bien mais c'est pas ce qui
mobilisait l'énergie de nelly blaye elle
elle ce qu'elle voulait c'était voir le
monde
écrire le monde donnait à lire le monde
elle voulait être journaliste là sa
carrière a commencé de façon assez
amusante parce que elle a lu dans le
pittsburgh dispatch le journal de son
patelin un article sur les dangers du
travail des femmes
c'est ce que c'est un ca veut travailler
après ça veut disposition d'argents le
droit de vote ça on s'en sort pas ça l'a
un peu énervé nelly blaye parce que sa
propre mère travaillait pour une raison
assez simple
le papa était décédé et elle en matière
de dangers du travail des femmes elles
voyaient comme seul risque le fait que
sa mère pouvait subvenir aux besoins de
sa famille c'est vrai que c'est embêtant
quand même alors donc elle a pris sa
plume nelly blaye et puis elle a écrit
au rédacteur en chef du pittsburgh
dispatch une lettre assez salée je me
suis là reçus en brenne style un certain
sens de l'argumentation de bonnes idées
il a publié la lettre il a offert un
poste de journaliste à son auteur voilà
comment à 21 ans nelly blaye devient
journaliste l'un de ses premiers
articles s'appelle s'intitule à quoi
sont bonnes
les jeunes filles et dans cet article
elle écrit ceci rassembler les filles
intelligentes
sortez les de la bourbe fait les grimper
à l'échelle de la vie et soyez-en
amplement récompensés qu'est ce qu'elle
nous dit nelly blaye elle nous dit
arrêtez vous regardez les filles dans la
bourbe et de vous demander pourquoi
elles sont dans la bourbe fait leur bon
sang de bonsoir la courte échelle
donnez leur une chance et c'est une
chance pour l'humanité toute entière la
question ce n'est pas d'où l'on vient
d'où les gens viennent c'est là où ils
vont mais les blagues elle elle voulait
aller partout où les autres journalistes
n'étaient pas allés elle voulait défier
les terrains à granit à l'information
nelly blaya voulait aussi faire
démonstration du fait que le rêve et la
réalité peuvent se rencontrer pour ça
elle s'emparait du rêve de jules verne
un tour du monde en 80 jours
dans le livre phileas fogg se fait
accompagner de son fidèle passe partout
elle décide de le faire seul contre
l'avis de son entourage qui lui dit que
ce serait quand même pas mal qu'elle se
fasse chaperonner je veux dire
accompagnée par un homme elle le fait
seule elle le fait en 72 jours
à son arrivée jules verne le jules verne
le bret publie une dépêche d'un journal
de la somme qui dit jamais douté du
succès de nelly blaya son intrépidité le
laissait prévoir
hourra hourra hourra l'énergie bien
diriger peut tout accomplir et la
personne qui a écrit ça vient d'en faire
la démonstration
c'est quoi la direction de la conquête
au fond c'est l'ambition tout simplement
et l'ambition sait jamais que pour
paraphraser oscar wilde viser la lune
pour atterrir à minima un minima dans
les étoiles les étoiles qui guident
celles et ceux qui ont l'esprit de
conquête en sociologie on appelle ça
déroule modèle un rôle modèle ben c'est
une personne admirable dans les pas de
laquelle on a envie de marcher c'est
plus que ça c'est aussi quelqu'un qu'on
a envie de dépasser et pour cela on est
prêts à se dépasser soi-même
alors on a un problème en matière
d'égalité femmes hommes les femmes
manquent de role models bah oui -2 4% de
personnages historiques féminin dans les
manuels d'histoire de seconde
et oui bien sûr on peut se dire que
c'est parce que tout simplement
peu de femmes voire pas de femmes ont
accompli de grandes choses pour
l'humanité jusqu'à ce jour on a le droit
de croire ça on peut aussi se poser la
question de savoir comment on écrit
l'histoire et par quels critères on
décide du fait que quelqu'un est
légitime pour entrer dans les manuels
d'histoire et surtout dans la mémoire
collective
quels sont les critères de légitimité
d'historicité qu'est ce qui fait qu'une
personne héros est reconnue comme étant
une personne importante et si ces
critères là finalement il était biaisé
et qu'il valoriser davantage les succès
des hommes que ceux des femmes
vous savez que ça a été étudiée que ça
porte un nom ça s'appelle l'effet
matilda l'effet matilda c'est le
phénomène d'invisibilité ation des
femmes dans le récit de l'histoire qui
procède de critères de légitimité
tendant à valoriser les succès des
hommes et à effacer ceux des femmes on
va prendre un exemple avec les messieurs
qui sont là pour nous un scientifique
dans notre esprit c'est quelqu'un qui a
des diplômes à laboratoire des étudiants
c'est quelqu'un qui va peut-être un jour
aller chercher un prix nobel à stockholm
c'est quelqu'un qui a des cheveux blancs
une moustache
voilà ce qu'est un scientifique
attendais pas avant de continuer j'ai
besoin de vérifier un truc via le wi-fi
là dans la salle et le wi fi non si en
attendant je vais vous je le broad est
un peu sur l'histoire du mi6 que je pas
si vous savez que le wifi en fait
comme le bluetooth et le gps ça procède
d'une technologie qu'on appelle la
technologie la mare du nom de celui qui
a inventé ce système voilà cent qui joue
kehrberg steve jobs faisait tous les
serveurs seraient pas grand chose bah
c'est qui c'est qui ce fameux la mare à
qui on doit tant bien mesdames et
messieurs je vous hante la mare hedy
lamarr assez sûre elle ressemble plus à
une actrice hollywoodienne cannes stein
et pour cause c'était une actrice
hollywoodienne
alors pour moi elle a fait beaucoup de
choses pour l'humanité elle a eu une vie
très riche une des premières choses
qu'elle a fait pour l'humanité ça a été
d'être la première actrice à être vus en
train de jouer un orgasme féminin dans
un film moi personnellement sûr que
c'est un grand progrès pour l'humanité
mais je vais quand même vous parlez de
wifi vous inquiétez pas elle s'est
mariée en fait parfois faux pas elle
s'est mariée à
un industriel autrichien on est dans un
étrange il avait flairé un bon business
il est commerce d'armes avec les nazis
et mussolini
voilà un type charmant vous allez voir
ce type
ben en plus d'avoir des clients tout à
fait recommandable il avait une certaine
vision des femmes et notamment de la
sienne ils estimaient qu'elle lui
appartenait que c'est un peu ça choses
donc il a très mal est partout
donc en fait quand ils allaient dans ces
rendez vous avec ses clients il
l'emmenait à l'équipe au début sans
comptant 1
c'est gentil monsieur est venu avec
cette jolie petite créature ça distrait
les yeux tout ça puis après il disait là
maintenant on va aborder des secrets
industriels militaires préparent une
guerre que ce serait bien si la dame
pouvait sortir le mari d'edie la
marquise au cou elle fait pas la
différence entre deux lettres de
l'alphabet véridique
j'ai mes toiles à la tout frais à côté
la fougère très bien à la super petit
peu de travail
voilà on est en trois points séparent
les travailler bon évidemment hedy
lamarr bale en a eu marre elle a pris
ses cliques et ses claques
elle est retournée à hollywood poursuit
sa carrière de comédienne elle est
devenue assez anti nazi 1 entre temps
quand même et elle était très navré de
voir les défaites des alliés dans
l'atlantique et notamment parce qu'on
n'arrivait pas à dégommer les sous
marins allemands parce qu'on les visées
mal on avait des problèmes pour les
radios téléguidé alors c'est sûr que si
par exemple on avait su faire la
projection multi fréquentiel ça aurait
été plus facile
on savait pas faire ça si elle savait
faire
ll savez comment c'est
parce que la fougère elles avaient des
oreilles elle avait une tête et surtout
la physique des fréquences ça l'a
beaucoup amusée
alors elle a écrit le schéma de
projection multi fréquentiel qu'on
utilise encore pour le wifi le gps et le
bluetooth
voilà je vous ai parlé de nelly blaya
des limes et des deals a marre et je
crois deviner ce que vous dites parce
que moi aussi je me suis dit la première
fois que j'en ai entendu parler
vous vous dites oh sees des femmes
d'exception des femmes d'exception et
ses envies nom des trains d'une femme
d'exception
ouais mais en fait c'est une énorme
arnaque
c'est une énorme arnaque parce que
l'exception sais quoi d'autre que la
rareté la curiosité ce qui est là pour
confirmer la règle du génie du pouvoir
de la conquête au masculin
vous avez un petit peu comme quand une
femme rentre dans un comics et puis
qu'on dit aller très bien
non non c'est pas la peine d'en envoyer
une autre de la ligue 1 deuxième non non
ce ne sont pas des femmes d'exception ce
sont des femmes exemplaires et pour vous
et que ce ne sont pas des femmes
d'exception je pourrais bien sûr vous
citer plein d'autres femmes je pourrais
vous citer marié takes à qui on doit la
première à maison à l'énergie solaire
je pourrais vous citer fanny workman qui
a cartographié la première l'himalaya je
pourrais vous citer marie walton à qui
on doit le à qui on doit le filtre à
particules je pourrais vous en citer
plein d'autres ça c'est les étoiles mais
je voudrais aussi vous parler de celles
et ceux qui nous font la courte échelle
celles et ceux qui nous permettent de
nous projeter dans les étoiles ce qui a
par exemple quand on est enfant c'est
nos parents ils font ça très
discrètement papas et mamans font ça
très discrètement quand il nous montre
au jour le jour que c'est parfaitement
banal normal évident qu'une femme
travaille qu'une femme gagne de l'argent
qu'une femme ait de l'ambition
qu'une femme et de l'audace qu'une femme
veuille conquérir le monde et pas
seulement des droits pour les femmes
qu'elles veulent conquérir cela c'est ce
qu'ils nous font la courte échelle nous
permettent de regarder les étoiles et
d'aller décrocher
new line je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]